true you know this you're really
confident mama
can I see you
Khloe Kardashian's daughter true gives
herself one seriously messy makeover my
favorite part about being a mom no
matter how tired you are whatever you
just it's complete Bliss Coco appears on
the Jennifer Hudson show and shares a
Sweet Home video of her four-year-old
kiddo getting into her mama's makeup I
turned around for two seconds I was like
I'm just gonna go to my room and grab
something and I come back I'm like oh my
gosh like okay well at least we're in
the Glam room and I'm gonna be okay
everything I could wipe down but you
know look at that face yeah Chloe she's
a self-proclaimed neat freak own
whatever it is in fact back in the day
she used to have a series on her YouTube
channel titled clothes CD where she gave
fans a look inside her super tighty
closets I was at The Container Store
which is like a crazy person's dream
fridge
yeah
and Pantry I like to kind of organize by
category so safe to say true's makeup
Adventure but her famous Mama's patience
to the test I like her to explore and do
her thing but I do have a cleaning
problem and I like things very organized
and clean so when she does these things
I encourage it but inside I'm like
freaking out honestly that love for
makeup just might run in the Kardashian
DNA her new favorite thing ever is doing
makeovers and no one can see until the
final look is done close nice Northwest
has showed off her makeup skills too
transforming her mom Kim Kardashian into
the Grinch and a minion
[Music]
away
in fact back in 2018 Kim told E.T that
at just five years old her daughter too
was getting into her kkw beauty products
I was getting ready today and she was a
little too quiet and I look over and she
has
just blue eyeshadow all over her entire
face sounds familiar right can I see you
she loves a before and after but back to
Chloe yeah take your time Chloe shares
true and an eight-month-old son whose
name she has yet to reveal with her ex
Tristan Thompson he's named but I
haven't announced it I haven't announced
it I haven't announced it yet at first I
really did not know what I was going to
name him I wanted to meet him and feel
him out a little bit yeah we still don't
know the name of baby number two but we
will soon I've been waiting for the
premiere of our show and I didn't know
it was going to be this far out so now
I'm just like if my daughter outs me I'm
screwed but Chloe does tease that her
Babe's name starts with the letter t
just like his big sister true and Dad
Tristan he's a happy baby which is
amazing and fans won't have to wait too
long to find out season three of the
famous family's Hulu series debuts May
25th and based on the trailer that
dropped last month it's gonna be a good
one I wish I could tell you this is
going to be a mild relaxing Serene
season
it's not
[Music]
foreign